[Music]
No
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
tonight we join Kyle and your Toronto
Raptors as we commemorate last year's
accomplishments in both the rafters and
their record books forever and to lead
us this evening would you please welcome
Kyle Lowry Wow such a special night on
behalf of my teammates the organization
my guys that aren't here Danni Kauai
Jain Lloyd Jane Lynn we want to thank
all you fans at his great city of
Toronto and the country of Canada we
wouldn't have been ever do this without
you guys
I want to shout all you guys out and I
want y'all to make some noise right now
real quick make some noise to me
so listen we got the special thing up
there right there we bought the Dell so
I want all my teammates all my teammates
you mark your mark search og come on
everybody get around me come on we go
and do this together and we're gonna
help I want you to help us count this
down we will go from five and we're
gonna bail this thing y'all ready
five four three two one
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Julie
[Music]
the NBA champions have enjoy their
emotional moments in Tehran